we will now turn
china which is in many ways you'll tell
us if i'm wrong here the opposite of the
US with a strong central planning for an
energy system which in so doing is
adding energy capacity more rapidly than
any other country in the world professor
Zhang perhaps you can tell us something
about what we should expect to see
happening in the world of energy in the
next 10 to 15 years in China and maybe
how that compares a little bit to the
rest of the world thank you it's really
a great pleasure to be here to join the
very interesting discussion and also
jumia opportunity to share with you some
of all perspectives so about china's
energy and co2 emission and just the
moderator emergent so i'm very important
and over to his meaning because China is
the largest energy consuming lesion so
in the world and last year the total
primary energy consumption reached 3.7
pennington jokowi coolant and if you
look at the mix the endless supply mix
so we will see still 66 66 percent from
co and and also the oil accounted for
approximately nineteen percent and in
Africa's 5.8 present non-fossil fuels
that means nuclear plus renewables Oh
together so it's about nine point nine
point eight percent so you can see Co
still coal and fossil fuels and the
potato call still dominated or any
supply mix and also for the Putin regime
so I general the Portland reaching
capacity also reached about twelve
twelve thousand gigawatt last year and
approximately sixty-five percent from
coal under and never guess
is about six it's about a three point
five percent and I'll and also at a
renewable recently for the past eight
forget it for the past two decades
within it's a very fast growth but
retinol the member is still there share
is very low for example the China is the
latest installation nation of inner
turbulence but the contribution for part
in the region it's only a five pointed
two percent and the solar energy and the
nuclear is about one point through
present and but for the renewable the
Hydra so for the protein region is
assure is very high it's approximately
21 present so this is the situation of
the anti consumption and the ordinary
shin so from this supply mix we can see
it also leads to the channel become also
the latest cabinet also a major in the
world so and right now we know and
approximately one quarter of the total
carbon dioxide emission in the world
from China comes from trainer and more
importantly approximately sixty percent
of increased carbon dioxide emission
from China so and and this is why it
happens so I think it's very much
related to three major drivers for
china's energy consumption and also co2
emission so why it's the
industrialization the second is the
urbanization the thread is the
modernization so because in the near
future with three major drivers they
replace so we can expect the channels
co2 imaging and energy consumption will
keep going up but i but we believe the
good read will be going down so
according to our recent projection this
based on quinoa MIT grande research
product so by the year 2020 so jenner
china's total energy consumption could
be approximately 55 billion things of
kinds of co equivalent five billion and
by the year twenty twenty it could be
palin six billion tins of equivalent so
and and also if relayed to the in
addition to address the co2 emissions
general how to also address that very
serious domestic in mental challenges so
I'm very happy I'm very anowar so I'm
very thankful for the imitation for me
to keep talking here because because I
said here i get rid of the smoked so he
begin so you know for this couple week
for this week padeen the smoke is very
serious the pollution index is soaring
very high so I so very much thank make
you happy to be here so and also to
address and not only the co2 images of
the air quality issues the China showed
a short stroll to take a substantial
efforts for the promote the renewable
energy and a known fossil fuels so
according to all projection so by the
year twenty twenty the non-fossil fuel
contribution could be fifteen percent
and by the year twenty or whether year
2030 it could be twenty twenty-five
percent and at after year 2030 the
increased energy consumption could be
supplied by the non-fossil fuels the
nuclear and the renewables search that
cannot seem to imaging could peek so at
a year or two thousand and authority so
this is the the pictures but the big
challenge is the Chinese economy
population is very hot so to address
this how to say the Kennedys to take a
substantial effort and also we need of
course we also need a policy yes we are
very centralized planning lesion so
China's policy approach is largely top
down so for the past ten years and for
example so we have our energy plan any
exercise from a central government to
the county comment the lorries the
government so in China and the very the
critical work
the energy planning is is to set legally
binding targets for energy co2 emission
and renewables so and each so this
targeted can kind of horse a cable
signal a message for mobilizing their
social resources to water areas so I
think it's very important in addition to
the National legally in addition to the
package and also there is also approach
is very unique in China is aggregating
the national targets into promises so
make the the provincial governors and
even the large the leaders of the
industry be responsible for energy
conservation and seemed to a medication
so and there is the agreement between
the government and a major and the
consumers and still three meters so I in
China so this is a su College command
and control brute command account for
approach but we also and also a risk
that a Chandler learn to use
market-based policy instruments so
including the text text policy and also
the prana and the energy conservation
subsidies investment and I renewable
energy you renewable electricity for the
interviews and electricity surcharge for
renewable development and also recently
so for the past through for the past
three years trainer a studied
cap-and-trade emissions carbon the
carbon dioxide emission cable and reach
a palace so in five cities and a permit
including bayesian and right now
according to just after you know the
third plane the thought police plenum
has already said very directions for
further reform kenneth economy and also
come up with very low domestica
corrections for reform train insanity a
collimated policy so according to the
the new reform initiative Tanner will
build a national
cape and a treat seguin better year
honey 20 so I'm just yesterday so I
received a call from the national
development and reform commission would
like me to join so a meeting next week
talking about the setting of the
national targets and how to this are
getting the National takis to two
provinces and what's kid what kind of K
approved to allocate that the co2
emissions into and oppresses so under
that means this isn't that means it's a
series because that eccentric remit have
a road map to the same cameo doesn't
come in the same requirement that orders
today the console request the national
development information it will
formulate a roadmap so and this this
major workers will be finished a better
year at the end of this year so I think
this is maybe that's the circlet
top-down approach so people based on a
present Chinese political system but I
think this is the the story for the
recently but this is the part of a story
was recently but also there is a new as
I go a momentum and because this is the
social awareness about yo mando
pollution and that the criminal contains
in China had release as Muslim Pia and I
think that because the Reserva social
awareness make it's possible for more
easier to implement Chinese this
kilometer energy policy okay it's a
larger if it's likely due to the smokes
Taylor with her okay thank you very much
sir Jang the you know I'm struck again
by a couple of things one is that with
the central planning approach the
dimensions of change that have been
achieved in China in all areas of energy
use and dwarfs other economies and and
other host nations so it's it's a quite
a remarkable achievement I'm also struck
in those some of us listen to Dan's talk
last night another talk on
communications and how you can take
different numbers and lots of very
interesting facts coming out one of
which is you know the tremendous growth
in renewables and in solar and others
which it is also quite spectacular at
the same time the growth in coal and the
dilemma that that creates to meet the
the societal needs for energy in China
and how do we balance those so we'll
talk about that but think of that as we
kind of as you think about rates of
market penetration and what it would
really take to have a greater percentage
for example of renewables it's just it's
an important aspect
you